NORTH KOREA.
ALL OF THAT TONIGHT'S FOCUS
IN TONIGHT'S BREAKING NEWS
OPENING MONOLOGUE.
♪ WE HAVE BIG BREAKING NEWS
TONIGHT.
"WALL STREET JOURNAL" JUST
OUT WITH A MAJOR REPORT.
HERE IS THE HEADLINE.
TRUMP LAWYERS SEEK DEAL WITH
MUELLER TO SPEED END OF
RUSSIA PROBE.
PUSHING BACK ON SOME ASPECTS
OF THE STORY.
HERE IS WHAT WE ARE BEING
TOLD AT THIS HOUR.
NEGOTIATIONS UNDERWAY ON HOW
THE PRESIDENT WILL BE
QUESTIONED BY THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL, ROBERT MUELLER.
AND THEY ARE CLOSE TO NOW
DETERMINING WHAT IS GOING TO
HAPPEN.
MY INTERPRETATION OF ALL OF
THIS MEANS THIS WITCH-HUNT
COULD FINALLY BE WRAPPING
UP.
THE PRESIDENT WOULD BE THE
LAST PERSON THAT MUELLER
WOULD WANT TO TALK TO.
BY THE WAY, TO ME, THAT
MEANS THAT A CONCLUSION IS
PROBABLY COMING SOON AND
THAT WOULD MEAN, YEAH,
DONALD TRUMP DID NOT COLLUDE
WITH THE RUSSIANS.
A BIG DEVELOPMENT.
WE'RE FOLLOWING CLOSELY
TONIGHT.
AND ALSO BREAKING, MORE
BREAKING NEWS ON A BOMBSHELL
DEVELOPMENT THAT WE BROKE ON
THIS PROGRAM LAST NIGHT.
SARA CARTER WILL JOIN US.
SHE HAS NEW INFORMATION
ABOUT THE URANIUM ONE
INFORMANT THAT IS SAID TO
HAVE PROOF OF A CLINTON
FOUNDATION QUID PRO-QUO.
NOW, VICTORIA TOENSING WILL
ALSO JOIN US, THE LAWYER FOR
THAT HER LINE, WILLIAM
CAMPBELL WAS INTERVIEWED IN
DECEMBER OF LAST YEAR BY OUT
FBI IN ARKANSAS AS PART OF
AN ONGOING INVESTIGATION
INTO THE CLINTON FOUNDATION.
ONGOING.
NOW, BECAUSE THE INFORMATION
THIS INFORMANT HAS,
DEMOCRATS PREIMIVELY IN THE
MEDIA, THEY ARE TRYING TO
DISCREDIT THIS INFORMANT WHO
SPENT DECADES OF HIS LIFE
SERVING HIS COUNTRY.
CONGRESSIONAL DEMOCRATS
RELEASING A MEMO YESTERDAY
TO THE HILL TRASHING THIS
INFORMANT WILLIAM CAMPBELL'S
CREDIBILITY.
THESE SMEARS WERE PICKED UP
BY CNN, FAKES NEWS, REUTERS
AND YAHOO.
HERE'S THE ONE THING THAT
NONE OF THOSE ORGANIZATIONS
NEVER REACHED OUT TO SICK
TORE I CAN'T
VIRE I CAN'T
VICT I CAN'T
VICTOR CAN'T
VICTORIAAN'T
VICTORIA T'T
VICTORIA TOENSING FOR A
COMMENT.
WE WILL GIVE HER A CHANCE TO
DEFEND HER CLIENT AGAINST
SMEAR.
THIS IS A PARTISAN LEFT WING
ATTACK JUST DESIGNED TO
PROTECT HILLARY CLINTON, HER
FOUNDATION, AND WHAT THEY
DID.
IT NEVER MADE SENSE TO GIVE
20% OF OUR URANIUM TO
RUSSIA.
THE LEFT IN THIS COUNTRY
THEY KNOW THIS FBI
INFORMANT.
HE WAS IN PUTIN'S NETWORK.
HE HAS DAMAGING INFORMATION
ON THE CLINTONS THAT
POTENTIALLY COULD SEND THEM
TO JAIL.
SO THEY ARE LASHING OUT.
VICTORIA TOENSING, SARA
CARTER WILL HAVE THE
DETAILS.
THAT'S COMING UP TONIGHT.
WE ALSO HAVE NEW INFORMATION
ON ANOTHER MAJOR BREAKING
NEWS STORY SPECIAL COUNSEL
JEFF SESSIONS IS CONTINUING
TO SUGGEST THAT HE IS
STRONGLY NOW CONSIDERING
DOING WHAT WE HAVE BEEN
SAYING FOR A LONG TIME
NEEDED TO BE DONE.
THAT WOULD BE APPOINTING A
SECOND SPECIAL COUNSEL TO
INVESTIGATE RAMPANT FEIS
FISA ABUSES AND ABUSE WITHIN
THE FBI AND THE DOJ.
HERE'S WHAT WE KNOW.
THE FBI LIED TO THE FISA
COURT BY USING AN UNVERIFIED
DOSSIER BOTTOM BOUGHT AND
PAID FOR BY HILLARY CLINTON
TO GET A WARRANT TO SPY ON
AN ASSOCIATE OF THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN DURING AN ELECTION.
THE FBI BROKE THE FISA LAW.
AND THEY ALSO DID NOT FOLLOW
THE BUREAU'S OWN PROTOCOLS
BY RELYING HEAVILY ON WHAT
WAS SOMETHING THAT THEY
THEMSELVES SHOULD HAVE
VERIFIED AND CORROBORATED.
NOW, REMEMBER, FORMER FBI
DIRECTOR ANDREW MCCABE HE
TESTIFIED WITHOUT THE
DOSSIER THEY WOULDN'T HAVE
EVEN HAD A FISA APPLICATION.
A HUGE DEVELOPMENT, MAJOR
SCANDAL, I KNOW THE MEDIA
IGNORES IT, THEY WILL HAVE
EGG ON THEIR FACE, ANOTHER
BREAKING TORE SENT TO,
PRESIDENT TRUMP FINALLY HAS
ISSUED A PARDON FOR
CHRISTIAN SAUCIER.
THIS WAS AN ISSUE WE TALKED
ABOUT FOR A LONG TIME.
YOU MIGHT REMEMBER OUR
EXTENSIVE COVERAGE OF THIS
CASE.
SAUCIER IS A FORMER U.S.
NAVY SAILOR.
HE WAS CONVICTED OF A FELONY
AND IMPRISONED FOR A YEAR
FROM, QUOTE MISHANDLING
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION.
HE TOOK A FEW PHOTOS WHERE
HE WORKED INSIDE A
SUBMARINE.
40-YEAR-OLD SUBMARINE THAT
WERE DISCOVERED ON SAUCIER'S
ASK DISCARDED CELL PHONE.
HE DIDN'T GIVE IT TO
ANYBODY.
THIS BECAME A HUGE ISSUE ON
THE 2016 CAMPAIGN TRAIL,
HIGHLIGHTING A MAJOR
DISPARATE IN OUR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM.
REMEMBER, HILLARY CLINTON
MISHANDLED AN ENORMOUS
AMOUNT OF TOP SECRET,
SPECIAL ACCESS.
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION ON
THAT UNAUTHORIZED PRIVATE
SERVER.
AND THEN SHE DELETED 33,000
SUBPOENAED EMAILS.
AND SHE RECEIVED NO
PUNISHMENT BECAUSE JAMES
COMEY, PETER STRZOK AND
COMPANY, WELL THE FIX WAS IN
AND THEY RIGGED THE OUTCOME.
NOW, MEANWHILE,
NOW, MEANWHILE SAUCIER DID A
DID.
HE WAS SENT TO PRISON FOR A
YEAR.
AND THANKFULLY PRESIDENT
TRUMP TODAY AND RIGHTLY
TODAY, HE CORRECTED THIS
INJUSTIFIABLE AND CHRISTIAN
SAUCIER CAN NOW MOVE ON WITH
HIS LIFE.
EVEN MORE BREAKING
INFORMATION TO TELL YOU
ABOUT.
FOX NEWS REPORTING THE HOUSE
INTEL COMMITTEE, THEY ARE
SENDING 10 KEY QUESTIONS
ABOUT THE DOSSIER TO TWO
MORE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
OFFICIALS.
ONE OF THEM WHO WORKED AS A
KEY ADVISOR FOR BARACK OBAMA
AND JOE BIDEN IS ACTUALLY
MARRIED TO A SENIOR FUSION
GPS EMPLOYEE.
NOW, THIS IS DRAWS
COMPARISONS TO DEMOTE A DOJ
OFFICIAL BRUCE OHR AND HIS
WIFE NELLIE WHO WORKED ON
THAT FAKE NEWS DOSSIER FOR
FUSION GPS.
OTHER SERVED AS THE NATIONAL
SECURITY ADVISOR TO BIDEN.
THIS SCANDAL IS GETTING
BIGGER AND BIGGER BY THE
DAY.
THE HOUSE INTEL COMMITTEE
CHAIRMAN DEVIN NUNES
REVEALED EARLIER THIS WEEK
THAT HE HAS RECEIVED SOME
RESPONSES ABOUT THE DOSSIER
FROM SOME TOP OBAMA
OFFICIALS.
OTHERS SO FAR REFUSING TO
COMPLY.
SO, NUNES IS NOW THREATENING
TO ISSUE SUBPOENAS, WHICH HE
SHOULD DO.
AND FINALLY, PRESIDENT
TRUMP'S MAJOR WIN WITH NORTH
KOREA IS SENDING THE MEDIA
INTO A HATE-FILLED FRENZY.
THE PARTISAN PRESS IS
ABSOLUTELY GOING APOPLECTIC
OVER THE FACT THAT
ENTREPRENEURSHIP'S PEACE
THROUGH STRENGTH APPROACH
DEALING WITH LITTLE ROCKET
MAN, KIM JONG UN IS NOW
YIELDING POSITIVE RESULTS.
WE MAY HAVE PEACE IN THE
KOREAN PENINSULA.
THIS BREAKING NEWS THAT THE
PRESIDENT IS AGREEING TO
MEET WITH THE NORTH KOREAN
DICTATOR TO DISCUSS
DENUCLEARIZATION IS NOW
APPARENTLY AGGRAVATING AND
INCENSING LIBERAL LAP DOG
MEDIA PEOPLE AS THEY ARE
PHYSICALLY INCAPABLE OF
REPORTING ANY POSITIVE NEWS
ABOUT THIS PRESIDENT.
WATCH THIS.
>> ROLL OF THE NUCLEAR DICE.
IN SOME WAYS THE PRESIDENT
KIND OF GOT BOXED IN HERE.
HE COULDN'T SAY NO TO THIS
COMMUNICATION.
>> ENTIRE FOREIGN POLICY AND
GOOD DEAL OF THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC FREAKED OUT WHEN THEY
THOUGHT TRUMP WAS GOING TO
GET IN A ROOM WITH THIS GUY
WITH NO CONDITIONS AND START
TALKING.
>> WE HAVE JUST GIVEN KIM
JONG UN SOMETHING FOR
NOTHING.
>> I'M VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
WHAT THIS ADMINISTRATION
WOULD BE WILLING TO BARTER
AWAY.
>> WHY HASN'T ANY OTHER
PRESIDENT EVER DONE --
THAT THIS MIGHT BE
PARTICULARLY RISKY OR EVEN
ON WISE MOVE?
THIS IS THE PRESIDENT WE
HAVE AND HE SAID YES TO
NORTH KOREA.
>> Tucker: BUT HE IS NOT
SENDING $150 BILLION IN CASH
AND OTHER CURRENCY AND HE IS
NOT GIVING BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS TO THE NORTH
KOREANS.
HE GAVE NOTHING.
BUT THE DESTROY TRUMP MEDIA,
THEY LOVE THE POLICIES OF
APPEASEMENT OF BARACK OBAMA
AND PRESIDENT CLINTON.
BOTH OF WHICH HAVE FAILED.
THIS POINT WOULDN'T BE
SURPRISING IF THE MEDIA
LITERALLY AWARDED NEVILLE
CHAMBERLAIN A PROFILE IN
COURAGE AWARD FOR COME PIT
LATE IN HIS NEGOTIATIONS
WITH ADOLF HITLER IN MUNICH.
LIKE WE HAVE BEEN SAYING THE
CANNOT STOMACH A LEADER WHO
PEACE THROUGH STRENGTH AND
STANDS UM TO DICTATORS.
ALL THEY WANT IS A PRESIDENT
TO GRABBLE AND COWER AND
KISS KIM JONG UN'S RINGS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS PROVING
HE WON'T DO THAT.
AS A RESULT HE IS WINNING.
HE GOT EVERY CONDITION HE
NEEDED AND A DISCUSSION WELL
ABOUT DENUCLEARIZATION WOULD
BE GOOD FOR THE WORLD.
HE IS NOT GOING TO REPEAT
THE ABSOLUTELY IDIOTIC AND
COMPLETELY FOOLISH MISTAKES
OF BOTH CLINTON AND BARACK
OBAMA.
NOW, BACK IN THE 1990S, BILL
CLINTON CAME UP WITH
BRILLIANT IDEA LET'S TRY TO
BRIBE KIM JOPG U.N.'S FATHER
KIM GEOLOGY ILL WITH MOST OF
SUBSIDIES IN HOPES THEY
WOULD ABANDON NUCLEAR
PROGRAM.
PRESIDENT CLINTON TOOK A
VICTORY LAP ON NATIONAL TV
PATTING HIMSELF ON THE BACK
FOR BROKERING A GREAT DEAL
FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
HE WAS WRONG.
LOOK.
>> THIS IS A GOOD DEAL FOR
THE UNITED STATES.
NORTH KOREA WILL FREEZE AND
THEN DISMANTLE ITS NUCLEAR
PROGRAM.
SOUTH KOREA AND OUR OTHER
ALLIES WILL BE BETTER
PROTECTED.
THE ENTIRE WORLD WILL BE
SAFER AS A WE SLOW ET SPREAD
OF NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
>> Sean: NOW BILL CLINTON
WANTS MASSIVE FOREIGN POLICY
BLUNDER SET THE STAGE FOR
NORTH KOREA TO ACTUALLY
DEVELOP NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
BILLIONS WASTED.
HE IS DIRECTLY RESPONSIBLE
FOR THE CURRENT SITUATION WE
FACE TODAY.
AND, OF COURSE, THERE IS
PRESIDENT APPEASEMENTMENT
HIMSELF BARACK OBAMA.
HE TRIED TO OUTDO BOTH
NEVILLE CHAMBERLAIN AND BILL
CLINTON WITH A TIMID
RECKLESS POLICY OF
APPEASEMENT TOWARDS IRAN AND
RADICAL MULL LAWS CALLING
FOR DEATH TO AMERICA.
SAME PEOPLE PROMISING TO
WIPE AMERICA AND ISRAEL OFF
THE MAP WHO BURN AMERICAN
AND ISRAELI FLAGS.
IN OTHER WORDS, THEY HATE
OUR GUTS.
THAT DIDN'T STOP OBAMA FROM
ORCHESTRATING ONE OF THE
WORST DEALS EVER IN THE
HISTORY OF MANKIND.
NOW, THE APPEASER IN CHIEF,
HE GAVE IRAN $150 BILLION
WHILE STILL ALLOWING THEM TO
SPIN THEIR CENTRIFUGES.
HERE IS OBAMA SURRENDERING
TO THE RADICAL MULL LATHS IN
CASE YOU ARE INTERESTED.
>> TODAY, AFTER TWO YEARS OF
NEGOTIATIONS, THE UNITED
STATES, TOGETHER WITH OUR
INTERNATIONAL PARTNERS HAS
ACHIEVED SOMETHING THAT
DECADES OF AN MOLS CITY HAS
NOT.
A COMPREHENSIVE LONG-TERM
DEAL WITH IRAN THAT WILL
PREVENT IT FROM OBTAINING A
NUCLEAR WEAPON.
THIS DEAL DEMONSTRATES THAT
AMERICAN DIPLOMACY CAN BRING
ABOUT REAL AND MEANINGFUL
CHANGE.
CHANGE THAT MAKES OUR
COUNTRY AND THE WORLD SAFER
AND MORE SECURE.
THIS DEAL IS ALSO IN LINE
WITH A TRADITION OF AMERICAN
LEADERSHIP.
>> Sean: NO, YOU, UNLIKE
NEVILLE CHAMBERLAIN, BILL
CLINTON AND PRESIDENT OBAMA.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS REFUSING
TO GIVE AN INCH WHEN IT
COMES TO ENCOUNTERING NORTH
KOREAN AGGRESSION.
WATCH THIS.
>> NORTH KOREA BEST NOT MAKE
ANY MORE THREATS TO THE
UNITED STATES.
THEY WILL BE MET WITH FIRE,
FURY, AND, FRANKLY POWER,
THE LIKES OF WHICH THIS
WORLD HAS NEVER SEEN BEFORE.
HE DOES ANYTHING WITH
RESPECT TO GUAM, OR ANY
PLACE ELSE THAT'S AN
AMERICAN TERRITORY OR AN
AMERICAN ALLY, HE WILL TRULY
REGRET IT ROCKET MAN IS ON A
SUICIDE MISSION FOR HIMSELF.
AND FOR HIS REGIME.
SCHWABB SEAN YEAH, FURY AND
FIRE FOR ROCKET MAN.
AND HERE'S SOMETHING THE
ABUSIVELY BIASED NEWS MEDIA
WILL NEVER TELL YOU.
WELL, SINCE THE 190S DONALD
TRUMP HAS BEEN WARNING ABOUT
THE GROWING THREAT POSED BY
NORTH KOREA.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THESE PEOPLE IN THREE OR
FOUR YEARS ARE GOING TO HAVE
A NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
THEY HAVE THOSE WEAPONS
POINTED ALL OVER THE WORLD
AND SPECIFICALLY AT THE
UNITED STATES.
WOULDN'T BE BE BETTER OFF
SOLVING THIS UNBELIEVABLE
AND BIGGEST PROBLEM.
WE CAN TALK ABOUT THE
ECONOMY AND WE CAN TALK
ABOUT SOCIAL SECURITY THE
BIGGEST PROBLEM THIS WORLD
HOW IS NUCLEAR
PROLIFERATION.
WE HAVE A COUNTRY OUT THERE
NORTH KOREA, SORT OF WACKO.
NOT A BUNCH OF DUMBIES AND
THEY ARE GOING OUT AND THEY
ARE DEVELOPING NUCLEAR
WEAPONS.
AND THEY ARE NOT DOING IT
BECAUSE THEY ARE HAVING FUN
DOING IT THEY ARE DOING IT
FOR A REASON.
>> Sean: ALSO TONIGHT.
WE HAVE EVEN MORE PROOF.
EXPOSING THE MEDIA'S
ANTI-TRUMP AGENDA.
NOW, ACCORDING TO THE NEW
MEDIA RESEARCH STUDY.
NEWS COVERAGE ABOUT
PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS NEGATIVE
IN JANUARY AND FEBRUARY.
91%.
I TOLD YOU BACK A LONG TIME
AGO JOURNALISM IN AMERICA IS
DEAD.
WELL WHAT WE HAVE NOW IS THE
MEDIA THAT IS ONLY AN
EXTENSION OF THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY.
THEY REJUDGE AT A TIME THE
TALKING POINTS.
THEIR SINGULAR PURPOSE IS TO
DO WHAT?
DESTROY PRESIDENT TRUMP AT
ALL COST AND THE TRUTH BE
DAMNED AND ALL OF THESE
STATISTICS PROVE IT.
NOW, IN THE MEDIA'S EFFORTS
TO DELEGITIMIZE DAMAGE THIS
PRESIDENT THEY HAVE ALL BUT
BLACKED OUT ANY POSITIVE
NEWS COMING FROM THE WHITE
HOUSE.
TAKE A LOOK AT TODAY'S
POSITIVE DATA.
TODAY'S JOB NUMBERS SMASHED